JILLIAN: WELCOME BACK,
REPUBLICANS ARE SLAMMING NANCY
PELOSI FOR HAVING MISGUIDED
PRIORITIES.
ONE CONGRESSMAN SLAMMING HER FOR
BRINGING MEMBERS BACK TO VOTE ON
MAIN AND TIGER KING LEGISLATION
INSTEAD OF PPP FUNDING AND
COVID-19 RELIEF.
JILLIAN: BRUCE WESTERMAN JOINS
US LIVE NOW.
THIS IS A PRETTY INTERESTING
TURNER OF EVENTS HAVE YOU BOTH
TAKING PLACE ON CANNABIS AND BIG
CATS.
COVID-19 RELIEF IS STILL BEING
NEGOTIATED.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> GOOD MORNING CARLEY AND
JILLIAN.
GOOD TO BE WITH YOU.
YOU KNOW, I WAS THINKING IT’S
THE LAME DUCK WE HAVE GOT A FEW
WEEKS OF LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
LEFT.
I WAS SHOCKED TO FIND OUT WE
WERE COMING BACK, AT LEAST PART
OF US WERE COMING BACK,
REPUBLICANS WERE COMING BACK TO
D.C. TO VOTE ON MARIJUANA AND
TIGER KING.
YOU KNOW, WITH COVID PEAKING.
WITH SMALL BUSINESSES CLOSING,
YOU KNOW, JAMIE HERRERA BUTLER
PROPOSED THAT WE DISCHARGE
PETITION TO SPEND SOME PPPP
FUNDS TO HELP THESE SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT ARE STRUGGLING
BACK IN SEPTEMBER.
AND THE SPEAKER HAS IGNORED
THAT.
AND YOU CAN’T MAKE IT UP.
I CAN’T BELIEVE WE ARE HERE BACK
IN D.C. WITH JUST A FEW WEEKS OF
TIME LEFT, AND THE GOVERNMENT IS
NOT FUNDED, THE MILITARY IS NOT
FUNDED.
BUT BY GOLLY WE ARE GOING TO
VOTE ON POT AND TIGER KING.
JILLIAN: I GUESS SOME PEOPLE
MAKE THE ARGUMENT THAT BOTH
SIDES ARE BLAMING EACH OTHER
RIGHT NOW FOR NOT GETTING
ANYTHING ACCOMPLISHED AS FAR AS
STIMULUS GOES WITH COVID-19
RELIEF.
LET’S GO AHEAD AND TAKE A LOOK
AT THIS.
THIS IS NANCY PELOSI AND CHUCK
SCHUMER STATEMENT AFTER BACKING
THE NONPARTISAN BILL MANY FAMILY
BUDGETS AND SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
AT THEIR BREAKING POINTS IN
LIGHT URGENCY OF MEETING THE
NEEDS OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
THE THEY HOPE THAT THE VACCINE
PRESENTS.
IT’S TIME FOR LEADER McCONNELL
TO SIT DOWN WITH DEMOCRATS TO
FINALLY BEGIN A TRUE BIPARTISAN
EFFORT TO MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
COUNTRY.
AT THIS POINT AFTER BACKING THIS
THEY ARE PUNTING IT OFF TO
McCONNELL.
>> THAT’S UNFORTUNATE.
BECAUSE WE HAVE FUNDING
REMAINING IN THE CARES ACT THAT
WE JUST NEATH NEED SOME TWEAKS
TO GET THIS FOUNDING OUT TO
BUSINESSES TO GIVE GOVERNORS
FLEXIBILITY ON THOUSAND SPEND
THE FUNDS.
IT’S UNFORTUNATE THE WAY PEOPLE
ARE HURTING ACROSS THIS COUNTRY
AND WE CAN’T MAKE A FEW TWEAKS
TO GET THIS NEEDED FUNDING OUT
THERE.
IT SPEAKS VOLUMES TO WHAT WE ARE
SEEING ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
JOE BIDEN SAID SOMETHING ABOUT
AND I’M GLAD HE ADMITTED THIS
FORGOTTEN RURAL AMERICA, I THINK
IT GOES DEEPER THAN THAT WE ARE
SEEING A DIVIDE THAT I BELIEVE
PEGGY NOONAN CAPTURED THIS BEST
BACK IN 2016 WHEN SHE WROTE
ABOUT THE PROTECTED AND THE
UNPROTECTED.
AND THEN BRET STEVENS WITH THE
"NEW YORK TIMES" FOLLOWED UNJUST
THIS PAST MAY AND HE TALKED
ABOUT THE REMOTE AND THE
EXPOSED.
I REPRESENT A LARGE RURAL
DISTRICT.
AND MY CONSTITUENTS DON’T HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO NOT GO TO
WORK.
THEIR JOBS REQUIRE THEM TO GO TO
AND THEY ARE EXPOSED.
THEY CAN’T WORK FROM THEIR
BASEMENTS.
AND WHEN WE COME BACK TO VOTE ON
POT AND MARIJUANA AND A LOT OF
DEMOCRATS ARE SITTING AT HOME IN
THE SAFETY OF THEIR BASEMENT
COLLECTING PAYCHECKS AND
BASICALLY THUMBING THEIR NOSE AT
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE WORKING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS FOOD IN
THE GROCERY STORE THAT IT’S
DELIVERED, THAT’S JUST HARD TO
TAKE.
CARLEY: JUST REAL QUICK, BECAUSE
YOU REFERENCED IT, BIDEN DID
MAKE COMMENTS ON RURAL AMERICANS
RECENTLY.
HE SAID YOU KNOW IT REALLY GOES
TO THE I ISSUE OF DIGNITY, HOW Y
TREAT PEOPLE.
I THINK THEY JUST FEEL
FORGOTTEN.
I THINK WE FORGOT THEM.
SO INTERESTING COMMENT FROM JOE
BIDEN THAT I HAVE A FEELING YOU
AGREE WITH.
CONGRESSMAN WESTERMAN, THANK YOU
SO MUCH.